[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Have you
played AppShip3000?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: No,
but I'm ready to.
And I'm standing here with Abe,
who helped build this fantastic
experience.
Abe, tell me all about it.
ABE HASKINS: Yes,
this is AppShip3000.
This is a collaborative,
Firebase trivia game,
where three people work together
to launch their app ship
and hit their moonshot.
It's pretty crazy.
Played with arcade
controllers out here
in this very loud
situation, where
it makes you yell to each
other and get all hyped up.
And it's a lot of fun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
So we're going to play it.
And maybe I'll give
you the microphone,
and you can sort of
narrate what's happening,
and maybe talk a little
bit about the tech?
ABE HASKINS: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
So for my fellow team players,
we've got Doug over here.
Doug, take a bow.
And Todd over here, who you
may know from such things
as Everything Todd Does.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, Abe.
I'm going to give you the mic.
ABE HASKINS: All right, awesome.
SPEAKER 2: Are we
already logged in?
ABE HASKINS: Yup.
Everyone's already
logged in, and they're
sitting with their rocket
primed for ignition.
In order to take off,
everyone has a specific color
they need to hit.
So let's give it a countdown.
In three, two, one, takeoff.
SPEAKER 2: Whoa!
Go, go, go!
ABE HASKINS: There we go.
There we go.
SPEAKER 2: Woo!
ABE HASKINS: Now, in
the game of AppShip3000,
the very first
thing that happens
is you will get prompted to
ask, have you played before?
Everyone here has.
Good.
And we'll dive
right into the game.
The very first question.
Who has it?
SPEAKER 3: I got it.
[INAUDIBLE]
ABE HASKINS: There you go.
There you go.
SPEAKER 3: Oh, no!
SPEAKER 2: Left, left!
ABE HASKINS: Those blinking
things up at the top
are asteroids, which will
absolutely destroy you.
[CHATTER]
SPEAKER 2: Left!
ABE HASKINS: Good, good.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: I have 98.
98?
ABE HASKINS: Good, good.
I'm amazed you knew that.
Good job.
[LAUGHS] How many Google
engineers does it take?
[CHATTER]
Lovely.
Good call, good call.
You can not be a
true Firebaser if you
think pineapples are ugly.
All right, while
this game's running,
I'll talk a little bit
about what's happening.
But it's a little
hard since they're all
shouting all the time.
SPEAKER 2: I have 93 and 01.
ABE HASKINS: Wha--?
SPEAKER 2: I have 93.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE] 94.
ABE HASKINS: Somebody
pick something.
You're running out of time.
Oh-oh.
SPEAKER 2: Oh-oh-oh.
ABE HASKINS: All
right, all right.
So while they're playing this
game, every movement they make
is being thrown off into the
Firebase real-time database.
And the real-time
database is taking that,
doing some analysis, updating
high scores and things
like that.
So absolutely every
move they make
is getting thrown off into
Google Cloud and Firebase
for analysis.
[LAUGHS]
All right, all right.
Oh.
[GROANS]
You got to watch out for
those asteroids, guys.
SPEAKER 2: It's
not eight, is it?
ABE HASKINS: No,
it is not eight.
It is definitely not eight.
Op, we're low on fuel.
Low on fuel.
If you miss this next
question, you are done.
SPEAKER 2: What Firebase
product allows the user
to search content
from [INAUDIBLE]?
ABE HASKINS: Ah-ah-ah.
Oh, you're so close.
SPEAKER 2: Right, right,
right, right, right!
ABE HASKINS: Oh!
Oh.
There you go.
That is the end of your
voyage, coming in at 1,154.
That is an OK score.
That is supremely OK.
Good job, everyone.
Thanks for playing.
[LAUGHS]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, Abe.
Thanks so much for that.
ABE HASKINS: Absolutely.
Any time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So we're actually
going to play another round.
So, uh, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]